I'm Kelly and here's everything we
learned from the animal crossing direct
February 20 2010 as confirmed labelled
RV Celeste Sahara Hicks and some new
characters Daisy may the turnip seller
flick the bug off host and CJ the
fishing tourney host to dodo birds are
your pilots to the island and their
names are Orville and Wilbur like the
Wright brothers New Horizons is the
first animal crossing game where you can
actually choose how your character looks
at the beginning from different options
instead of taking a quiz that determines
how you look and there's a range of new
hairstyles and more variety at the very
beginning of the game you can select the
plots of land that the first two
villagers on your island move into but
you can also select plots of land for
additional residents ahead of time so
they don't ruin your town confirmed
buildings looks cranny able sisters the
museum the campsite and also you can
upgrade the Town Hall and Isabelle will
be there you can move your facilities
and your house after you place them so
you can always fix your town in Neuilly
if you were the mayor of your town this
time you're the resident representative
as part of an island relocation vacation
package hosted by Tom nooks company
because Tom Nook continues to be a
shrewd businessman when you're
decorating your house you can push and
pull things like you would in previous
Animal Crossing games but you can also
activate a happy home designer style
mode lets you click and drop furniture
instead it doesn't have touchscreen
support though so it's just controller
the island designer app in the Nook
phone lets you late paths and basically
change the Train of your island at will
so you can add slopes rivers cliffs and
even staircases to get around your
Island a lot easier people are going 8
about the stairs
I watched a 5 minute YouTube video today
about the stairs so in the past when you
invited someone to your town they might
have brought like an axe or a shovel and
like cut down all your trees or planted
pitfall seeds or something now in new
horizons people who come to your town
actually can't bring tools like axes and
shovels unless you guys have registered
as best friends so people can't just
ruin your town did I talk about the tool
wheel yet there are certain things you
can unlock through the course of the
game and one of them is a tool wheel
kind of like a weapon wheel in shooters
but for your tools so you don't have to
like rummage through your pockets or go
through the d-pad
and you can just select the tool you
want that's nice
the director confirmed fishing tourneys
and bug offs as normal events that
happen throughout the year but holiday
events like bunny day are part of free
update the first ones coming on March
20th and these events aren't actually in
the game at launch they come with the
free updates over the year possibly
discourage you from time traveling and
just doing everything in one fell swoop
this is the first time you can choose
whether you're in the northern or
southern hemisphere which is cool for
people in places like Australia you can
call a rescue service to come get you if
you get lost and don't know how to get
around your Island you can get a nook
miles ticket which takes you to small
deserted islands that are not the island
you live on and there you can get
resources fish catch bugs and meet other
villagers that you haven't met before
we knew before then you could earn nook
miles for doing different challenges
around the island but those nook miles
can also be used to pay off your debt
instead of using bells if you want
amiibo support was detailed including
amiibo cards and you can use it to
invite villagers to a campsite and also
use a photo shoot mode it's a very weird
feature you basically scan the amiibo
and then they come to a little set and
you can pose them and have them do
things and then takes a votive it's
really something the direct also
confirmed that there's gonna be pocket
camp crossover in the future so if you
deleted pocket camp it might be a good
idea to reinstall there's also something
called nook link for the Nintendo mobile
app which isn't often used but you can
use it to scan designs with QR codes you
can also use a voice chat if you want to
using nuke link and you can text using
it and your texts will show up as speech
bubbles in game new click is coming out
March 2020 quote-unquote soon after
launch with no specific release date so
that's everything we learned from the
animal crossing new horizons direct
thanks for watching and for more on Elm
crossings stay tuned to game spot
[Music]